[Música]
buenas tardes
mi plan no era hablar un poco de lo que
caló dijo cita pero me va a robar a mí
mismo es 30 segundos para decirles que
tal vez muchos de ustedes yo siempre he
sido fanático de ser buenos y me amanecí
viendo los vídeos me enteré que lo
estaba haciendo acá en dominicana soy de
los que compran la boleta sin saber
quién es que va a hablar y realmente
pues estoy muy orgulloso estar acá en
este escenario y lo más interesante tal
vez es que en un principio yo pensé que
les iba a hablar de desarrollo de
software pero y aunque sí es fue mi
primera compañía
y realmente al día de hoy seguimos
trabajando con él
y es algo
la
creo que ese primer set que yo hice esas
primeras tres iteraciones de la compañía
de software me llevaron a aprender mucho
creo que
cuando uno trabaja cuando no conoce
gente se crean muchas cosas igual
me di cuenta que una vez esa empresa
estaba funcionando yo quería ser más yo
quería hacer más cosas como desempleados
teníamos muchos clientes teníamos toda
una serie de cosas todo como que
funcionaba muy bien y
yo quería más y ahí fue donde puedes
empezar
me dediqué a leer y a entender cómo es
que pueden haber más cosas como hay
empresas que son como la mía que valen
millones de dólares le hizo un
emprendimiento de bree sobre star wars o
las aceleradora de empresas sobre todo
este montón de términos fueron días
completos en ese barrio que es el
internet
y llegué a una conclusión y dije bueno
ok me topé específicamente con este
término y iphone le dije es lo que yo
quiero ser para quienes no saben lo que
es un emprendedor en serie es esa
persona que monta la compañía la hace la
cree se la pone a funcionar y después
vuelve a empezar otra vez y me dije a mí
mismo es lo que yo quiero hacer y desde
entonces me he dedicado a tratar de
llegar a ese punto
toda esta investigación me dijo a mí y
bueno es bastante sencillo no hay que
buscar una buena idea
hay que ir donde alguien que te dé
dinero hay que montar el negocio hay que
crecer ese negocio aquí el delincuente
de más dinero aún seguirlo creciendo
venderlo o salir a bolsa para poder
mudarse una lista en el caribe
y todo esto es bien interesante porque
eso lo que la mayoría de la
documentación de emprendimiento te dice
pero cuando llegamos a la realidad
cuando empezamos a hacer todo esto nos
damos cuenta que no está en una idea
sino que es que saber mucho sobre un
tema para entender qué es idea buena nos
damos cuenta que la rama de inversión
acá son difíciles de conseguir que
arrancar un negocio sumamente complicado
y mucho más complicado de lo que parece
crecer lo es sumamente difícil no hay
capital de seguimiento crece un negocio
tiene múltiples locales son múltiples
ciudades múltiples países es algo que
muy poca gente ha logrado hacer y tal
vez el principal problema del modelo
tradicional es que no hay una salida no
hay estas grandes empresas de tecnología
que te quieran comprar no hay estas
grandes fondos que están dispuestos
invertir dinero para recuperarlo cuando
cuando la empresa lo amerite pero lo que
más me chocó de todo esto es que estamos
en una isla en el caribe
yo puedo bajar a malecón y beber me la
piña colada no tengo que hacer todo este
gran flujo
y pues llega a la conclusión de que todo
lo que yo leí no funciona realmente hay
muy pocas excepciones de gente en
latinoamérica que ha logrado hacer esto
entonces lo que nos queda es
experimentar y de eso es que realmente
quiero hablarles quiero hablarles de
muchos los experimentos que he corrido a
través de los años yo hoy la gente con
la cual yo me relaciono porque
a mí la gente me pregunta que tú eres
una respuesta sencilla yo tengo una
compañía desarrollo software mi
respuesta compleja es yo me dedico a
encontrar personas que tienen ideas y
potenciales negocios y nos dedicamos a
levantar compañías juntos
entonces hay ciertas cosas
son necesarias para que esto pase y les
puedo hacer una historia de uno de
nuestros primeros inversionistas se
llama guillermo el día que yo conocí a
guillermo nos juntamos a almorzar
simplemente porque él tiene un interés
grandísimo escobar que space es igual
que nosotros y a las cinco de la tarde
yo me tuve que levantar de la mesa chile
guillermo disculpa mente aunque ahí
porque no quiero una entrega de un
premio de una cosa que nos habíamos
ganado su respuesta fue que tú haces
mañana
y el sábado fuimos a ver el local donde
montamos nuestro power space
dos semana más tarde yo salí de casa de
guillermo con 250 mil pesos en efectivo
para comprar unos equipos usados que
íbamos a necesitar que nos iban a dar un
ahorro y en la puerta de su apartamento
yo dije en este tipo o sea yo lo acabo
de conocer y yo tengo un montón de
dinero en efectivo que yo perfectamente
podía ir y eso es confianza sin embargo
la confianza ese mismo nivel de
confianza me llevó a mí a durar un año y
tres meses invertido en un proyecto
junto con 10 personas más bajo una
propuesta de inversión en la cual
nosotros íbamos a hacer todos los
partners
que cuando las cosas aterrizaron cuando
todo terminó
encajando donde debería de ser la
propuesta no tenía sentido para nosotros
y todos perdimos ese tiempo
y creo que perder tiempo son las cosas
más difíciles que nosotros podemos tener
y muchas de esas cosas se convierten en
problemas que vemos yo creo que el
principal problema que todo el mundo
tiene a la hora de que le arrancar un
negocio es de que yo voy a vivir
y a mí personalmente nunca me ha pasado
cuando yo renuncié a mi empresa para
perdón donde trabajaba para arrancar mi
primera empresa de software yo en ningún
momento tuve miedo de regresar a mi
trabajo
sin embargo hablando con otro amigo con
otro emprendedor estábamos en un grupo
una sala más grande éramos tres personas
uno le estaba tratando de explicar ese
problema al otro
él le decía era un tipo inteligente yo
no trabajado contigo pero tú un
excelente profesional
yo sé que tú puedes ser excelente en
cualquier cosa que te propongas lo peor
que puede pasar es que la mitad de la
gente que tenga esta habitación te
ofrezcan trabajo
si la empresa se quiebra
y tú eres una persona suficientemente
buena como para haber arrancado esa
empresa no te preocupes que va haber más
trabajo
y el miedo se presenta en muchas formas
del vuelvo a la historia cuando abrimos
el cover king space yo recuerdo que me
desperté un día a las 3 de la mañana
manejé hacia donde iba a ser el sitio
dure una media hora ya y cuando volví
hacia mi casa yo dije si esto va a pasar
definitivamente perdió el miedo
paso
sin embargo volvemos a lo mismo o sea
esas primeras etapas realmente en todas
las etapas todo el que tiene un negocio
te puede decir qué
yo no puedo hablar con mi pareja con mi
familia con mis socios con mis empleados
hay gente con la cual yo no puedo
discutir muchas cosas de negocios y eso
es algo que
que mucho muy poca gente habla de ese
tema cuando habla de emprendimiento
ese sentimiento cuando tú
no puedes hacer nada porque tú sabes que
tu empresa va a cerrar
ese momento en el cual simplemente hay
que aceptar las cosas y entender que
cuando tú te pusiste arrancar ese
negocio que invertiste esos recursos ese
tiempo ese dinero
con el riesgo de que ese momento iba a
pasar creo que todo el que ha cerrado
una empresa sabe que si hubiera tomado
decisión antes de haber ido mejor pero
su miedo que hay que poder superar hay
que buscar la forma de trabajar
también hay que tomar en cuenta que la
mayor cantidad de la gente no se da
cuenta de todo lo que pasa antes
de esos momentos importantes que lo que
realmente ven nuestros clientes y
nuestros usuarios ese momento en el cual
se da cuenta que todo ese arduo trabajo
se convierte en momentos se convierte en
cosas importantes
seguramente en experiencias para las
personas ese momento en el cual celebra
el primer año de tu empresa con tus
clientes ese momento en el cual tú
celebras tú que rompiste esa barrera
mágica que las empresas a los tres años
estadísticamente hablando quiebra 85% de
las empresas a nivel mundial quiebran
ante los primeros tres años
sin embargo podéis ver la felicidad de
enseñarle a toda la gente que todo
precios
qué es lo que tenemos un año trabajando
ahora es una realidad
y este mundo del emprendimiento está
lleno de todo tipo
recuerdo como ayer primero eventos de
emprendimiento que organizamos este tipo
surfista de cabaret es en suba al
escenario y se pone habrá de los super
palitos de moringa
cuando la moringa estaba de moda
en ese escenario habían unas 70 personas
cada una tenía tres votos y cinco
agentes pensaron que eso era una buena
idea
esa persona hoy en día tiene una empresa
y esa empresa le ha ido súper bien
y al día de hoy yo todavía estoy
sorprendido de que le haya ido bien
o esas sorpresas cuando muchacho con 19
años el día que tú lo conoces te dice yo
quiero montar un fondo de inversión de
emprendimiento
le dice
estamos muy lejos de eso en este país la
empresa para invertir y en lo que
responde ponemos para otro país
y efectivamente eso él hizo el año
pasado yo él cerró su primer fondo de
inversión fondo a 10 años
entonces sobre esas sorpresas y son esos
momentos que uno dice bueno
estamos haciendo esto por múltiples
razones cada quien tiene
un norte diferente ese momento en el
cual un equipo
está trabajando en la playa en su
emprendimiento cuatro personas que viven
en cuatro países diferentes que volaron
hacia el mismo sitio para planificar la
siguiente etapa de su empresa
y tengo una empresa que tiene que ver
con viajes que les encanta todo ese tema
bien publicando fotos de donde sea que
ellos van
pero ese compromiso de trabajar ese
momento en el cual uno no para una
diferente cosa
yo aprendió algo bastante de esta
persona y se llama catherine porque en
un evento a ella le preguntaron
cuál es tu plan b
y ya no entendía la pregunta como así
que no hay plan b es que este es el
negocio esto es lo que vamos a hacer es
lo que estamos haciendo
esos momentos de cansancio extremo donde
tú simplemente sabes que tienes que
seguir pero
el cuerpo no te da
porque en todo este tema de
emprendimiento tenemos que tener mucha
pasión para hacer las cosas todo lo que
tiene que ver con empresas de pasión
pero que tiene muchísimo cuidado porque
hay gente que cree que nada más es tener
pasión la pasión es importante pero a
nadie realmente le importa que la
cantidad de esfuerzo que tú hagas la
gente lo que interesa son los resultados
yo quisiera cerrar con unas cuantas
cosas y yo creo que son las realidades
del otro crear negocios en este país
aquí un emprendedor en serio
nosotros somos emprendedores en paralelo
la gran mayoría la gente no se puede dar
el lujo de renunciar a su trabajo para
meterse 100% de un negocio estamos todos
trabajando en 4 y 5 kos al mismo tiempo
y de verdad provecho en ese momento en
el cual ustedes pueden enfocar todo su
recurso legal
por alguna razón contrario a todo lo que
dice toda la literatura la gran mayoría
de los emprendedores exitosos que yo
conozco no tienen socios aquí no lo sé
no sé por qué pero en dominicanas eso
pasa entonces no se detenga por eso
la gente que es están realmente
trabajando sus empresas están tan
ocupados en sus empresas que no tienen
tiempo para está sonando
y eso es otra cosa que yo me daba cuenta
al estar trabajando con emprendedores
nosotros debemos de salir a buscar a
esas personas para integrarlos en el
ecosistema
y tal vez una de las cosas más
importantes es que
no es ser emprendedor porque el
emprendedor es porque queremos recuperar
los recursos que invertimos en eso y
tenemos que vender tenemos que facturar
porque en este mundo en el cual vivimos
donde el capitalismo lo más importante
el dinero en sí lo que representa es que
yo quiero que tú siga existiendo
si alguien me compra mis productos si
alguien compra mi servicio significa que
ellos están depositando su trabajo
en que yo siga existía
entonces las empresas tienen que
facturar tú no gana nada teniendo un
desarrollo de software que tiene seis
meses haciendo lo que tú no ha vendido
absolutamente nada
tal vez lo más importante es que tenemos
que empezar
yo no lo tenía como parte lo que quería
decir pero en esta semana por pura
coincidencia la vida dos buenos amigos
uno acá y otra en costa rica murieron
accidentes de tránsito
uno de ellos iba a lanzar su estado
viendo semana
yo sé que lo que estamos esperando
porque siempre hay una excusa porque no
le dedicamos el tiempo a las cosas que
queremos hacer
y tal vez lo más importante que yo
quiero decirle a todos ustedes es que
tenemos que disfrutarlo en todo momento
porque
es el punto el punto es que duramos la
gran mayoría nuestra vida trabajando
porque no
por qué no hacerlo de una manera que sea
bueno para nosotros
te vas